[Music]
three two one action [ __ ] a [ __ ]
welcome to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we got a mix-and-match cast that
you've never really been seen never
before now I'd like an affirmative
action time we are so diverse
oh we're just missing a Latino
I look for years but she has kind of
like Asian Latino yeah exactly we got
[ __ ] by the Spaniards to pair it up a
little bit like this is [ __ ] egg you
guys got the whole this is the Platte
crew crew and Jayden ativ you got all
these mix-and-match is so true you know
um this group of friends are like we're
kind of weird right like we're so
multicultural like that's putting it
very lightly [ __ ] multi-coat like not
even just a race thing though but like
our interest yeah are so freaking
different yeah that's true
pretty [ __ ] difference how the hell we
all became friends and that's kind of
what brings us here today right we're
gonna do a deep dive on conspiracies
today yeah so this whole every time you
guys see a video of us you know a lot of
people have been asking oh I love it
when you and Steve go in and talk about
some real deep conspiracy stuff when you
go into history or you go into race or
politics or anything so we assembled a
dream team of people who wanted to get
together and talk about deeper [ __ ] but
in a funny way dream for me also before
we got on the air we were talking about
how there's all kinds of different kinds
of black people especially because you
know recently we've been dealing with
something you know with with with a
certain guest in a certain subject and a
certain topic of race and you know yeah
what about it well one of the biggest
things is you don't have enough black
representation on JK news is what I
heard okay yeah I guess I mean except
for you guys's guess we had to have an
spawn here today
that's crazy about that - is that just
black Yvonne general art like we were
saying have this diversity in our group
ourselves within being in the black
community it's like I'm separate from a
certain kind of black person right like
I'm like the nerdy kind so for like
until was the doll cover joke since 2003
or like whiskey illegal not even can't
fill it was illegal to be a black nerd
up until 2003 or something like that
Terkel was not one he would it wasn't
cool yet it was kind of I had a legit
crush on him though he was just fine I
did not like Stefan I like nerdy ass
circle and I like screech those were my
[ __ ] my entire life I would have had
such a fat crush on you it always hurts
when she says this and then she
complements me after I was a black nerd
yeah she was like no I just I just
settled I didn't see color I just saw
nerd that's the mess yeah but that's
that's the thing right is like we're not
all monoliths or whatever so I don't
like ever representing my race because
I'm the last person that should
represent race ever well can we have a
serious discussion about black
stereotype for right now like I think
that I love watermelon I like fried
chicken I love watermelon
I don't need chicken in three years I
heard that black people don't like Star
Wars
is that true black people love anime so
I like to say like black people aren't
like generally nerdy or whatever go to a
convention oh yeah well a black person
there they [ __ ] love enemy I'm
actually not that much into enemy but if
he's at an anime convention he better
like if you talk to like 10 black people
you're gonna find a bunch of them in
there who are just examine those
normal-looking ones yeah aren't pretty
inanimate normal-looking black person
the ones that are not at [ __ ]
Wow no just the ones that archaic
conventions because I feel like a very
specific kind of person that goes to a
convention and it's just like you can
pick that person out of the crowd where
you're just like like nerd [ __ ] is more
accepted now no it is maybe there was
like closeted like black nerds and then
there are many that I knew growing up
nerd [ __ ] is just Asian culture okay
stranger things there's that there's a
whole diverse cast of nerds oh yeah
that's a movie they put this is a Jump
Street like 21 Jump Street yeah a change
where they went back to school and
they're like what is this the jocks were
supposed to be there like not been the
Nerds or the cookie it's like what I
loved how I what's-his-face was an
Eminem fan yeah he had like the Slim
Shady haircut just wants to talk about
em oh no way remember when that person
was an Eminem fan and speaking about a
different type of black person okay
Eminem not true my name is completely
white actually flying feel like he's the
only guy in the rap game that I really
have like he had the stamp of approval
like right like there were some people
talking [ __ ] but no one really does like
the way that he is a lea or like all
these other you know white rappers came
out he grew up in it too that's a big
it's just undeniable someone fronting it
was like someone that grew up in it and
had to actually get beat up all the time
because I mean he was urban that's what
I did that that's who is that black for
the longest time has been you know
paired with urban and I mean I put in a
minute miss he's urban but he's not
necessarily is black like those two you
separate or they should be separate
because sometimes people say like oh you
know it's not like you talk black I'm
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
yeah basically what I think that you
sound like you're you're uneducated that
you sound ignorant that kind of [ __ ] so
it's like I never liked like those two
things being paired together I think you
sound black like I'm like what does that
really mean and then they when they try
to go into it it's like do you know what
I actually know about like my history
and what another black person has
absolutely no [ __ ] idea
and then on less black oh it's crazy oh
this is a video on cut right where they
were like ranking how black a person was
like looking at them and talking cut cut
the YouTube channel how black a person
you mean like dark day or no personally
got two from one to ten who go to like
jay-z ten of them and they were like at
least black most black they like put him
on a they put my let's go
and one of there was the Black Panther
guys who were ranking them and there was
a dude from Nigeria who came up and then
they were like no you're not black and I
was like wait what he's like black is
black
oh yeah slipping his explanation for it
and this is what I'm about those did the
split between all of them but we're
talking before the cameras came on is
that they were like you haven't been
through the experience of a black
American yeah black American culture is
different because you're in a country
where everyone is the same you don't
have that same feeling and he was said
that feels like yeah I never really felt
like I was black until I came so their
definition was like the black American
experience I mean that was for that it
was interpretation so for the Black
Panther guys it was like for us black
means this and then for the F guy even
he was like yeah I didn't even know what
it meant to be black until I came to the
states cuz he's in the country 99%
people look like you see yeah
thought about being black you're just
I'm just me you know I'm just like in
Nigerian wherever so I'm like oh man
that is insane cuz like there's like you
know definitely black Americans there's
Caribbean black West Indy black and then
there's like African like yeah so
[ __ ] different like all of them what
you just described is what you just
described is how I feel at when I met
Chuck E Cheese without a kid you can't
go to Chuck E Cheese without a kid I beg
for my birthday party you can if you
walk in looking like you're like oh
maybe like just being like oh how you
doing that yeah I'm sure for the pizza
they're like well that guy looks like a
dad I school they're like you don't
sound like the non Asian kids were like
you don't sound Asian and I'm like what
the [ __ ] do you expect to me to be like
hi hello my name is Joe hi
you know like what the [ __ ] they're like
oh you don't sound Chinese well first of
all not China but like there are a lot
of [ __ ] ignorance man I think now
kids are just smarter yeah just more
well it's more conversation yeah yeah
cuz like at my school like it's it's
interesting because how you were talking
is how I felt because it was like
predominantly white and then a
sprinkling of Asians and then a lot of
Mexicans but the Mexicans like they all
spoke Spanish or like they would hang
out in their own group like they would
like have their own group and then go
like all the white people were over here
but I wasn't white either and then they
I felt very yeah you didn't sneak in
with the nice tens and you've been like
oh I never learned spine no because
where we live everyone thinks you're
Mexican all the time I know because like
well they speak like they's like
Spanglish you know but like you know
they would speak Spanish to each other
right sitting there like I don't know
whatever taught me I'm sorry there's
people here like oh you're white passing
or like not to white people
no cuz then did you go over to the group
of white people and you're just like hey
call me mother act an ethnic friend know
how you could never be white passing if
I said have you ever sat down in a group
with a group of white supremacist you
like hello my way
you know though because I do have like a
couple of friends that are mixed and
like you can kind of tell like both
backgrounds together so like some things
like I I feel like for me only being
Asian I can only relate to this Asian
side and so when you said something
white I'm like that's funny because my
little white thing to say later we're
gonna have some tuna casserole yeah
right yeah that's what happened in my
family every word like yes sir yeah it's
cuz it's funny you mentioned that
because like I'm a hundred percent
Japanese but I'm pretty much as white as
they come you're pretty why it's the
running joke amongst everyone in this
company that's like he's he's the
whitest guy that comes you're like more
like stoner wait what generation not I'm
like depending on the side that you like
mother or father styling three or fourth
generation so I'm pretty great deep I'm
pretty far down there so and that's a
lot of my other friends too like you
don't meet very many like
first-generation Japanese people in the
States anymore like for the most part
they've been here see our age yeah yeah
so it's really bizarre because I'm a
hundred percent like if you follow the
lineage back like yeah just Japanese
people all the way back but if I go to
Japan like yeah you look like that
[ __ ] white no I don't look like them
though like I don't dress like them like
I have the same manners untrained eye
you do maybe yeah thank you don't but
you do oh okay well you go to a soccer
menu you look like you fit
would you freak with the non-japanese
you gotta keep them the bloodlines pyram
yeah right yeah so there's no like what
you look like on the outside but then
people like in that video are there's a
certain your ethnicity on the inside
should match that that's because all the
time people are like hey can you
translate this Japanese and I'm just
like oh I'm gonna you're in for a rude
awakening
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm looking
at but meanwhile they're just like hey
what kind of what kind of lawn care is
product should I get like well actually
propane and propane accessories for the
long grass yeah
older Mexican ladies always try to talk
Spanish to me and like they'll just come
up on the street and I'm like no habla
espanol and they're like they get mad
and they get mad in English they're like
[ __ ] no Spanish - Mexican that's so
funny because you're getting shamed for
like I could talk to me and he was
trying to talk to me about barbecue and
I was like I don't really get to
barbecue should know this [ __ ] this is
your culture you know that's a weird
thing to about culture and like what
people claim because even with like
Spanish and like most lab people don't
think about them being indigenous first
they think about the Spanish person
that's let me nuts smash it when they
came over because when they conquer
they're like hey we're gonna make
everything mixes in like that and now to
the point now where someone now will get
mad at you for not being Spanish I'm
really that wasn't really her culture
originally it invaded the Philippines
but I don't know a lot of Filipinos that
speak Spanish there's also garlic don't
you guys have numbers in Spain and a
useless us I don't know any $2 I know
more Spanish than I know if it's a girl
from working at a restaurant in a
restaurant Spanish restaurants like
taking their order you know like like
the cooks are like usually Mexican and
so they'll like just start speaking
Spanish - like like Caliente you know
like there's a Philippines have a bunch
of Spanish name city isn't you yeah it's
like a hybrid yeah yeah they really got
Jose's and they make a lot of like
Mexican Spanish last names yeah you know
American colony - the Philippines was
America right we try to take that
because we're trying in Japan right like
that's part of life before that yeah
well before that before that it was an
American colony lately - hundreds were
there fighting lady
because I know that there's a Filipino
sign out whether there's a Filipino or
something that it's called it I think it
was called the spanish-american war so
all of the former Spanish colonies
America when they were building as an
empire was going through and I think it
was throwing Teddy Roosevelt or
something but they they took over and
they when they won the Philippines and
then they had it for a little bit
well we have a base there I mean my dad
was stationed in the Philippines but
after World War two so then when they
came and liberated the Philippines from
the Japanese
that's when they came in and I think it
was funny because they're like the
Filipinos one of the Americans out and
when the Japanese came through a life
actually we couldn't be a lot worse
America's way better than the Japanese
yeah that's pretty funny and it's all
it's all perspective in context and you
were saying when you were in Japan they
look at you and go that's in America oh
yeah a hundred percent like I'm not
accepted there nor I am here so like
everywhere I go yeah like I look like
them and don't talk to me but then
Japan's really racist in a way where the
the whole place is just one race it's
like that in Iceland I think are the two
last countries where it's like my that
race and not chance yeah so then they
have a word for us called Nikkei which
is like Japanese born overseas so so and
then that's why when we count the
generations the first generation is the
people that move here like my parents oh
so now that again is the first born oh
because usually the first generations
who was born here in American terms
right for Japanese when they say what
generation are you they go oh you're the
first generation to emigrate that would
be okay and in the second generation to
emigrate third fourth or whatever will
be the kids from then on yes same in the
Philippines to like my dad's full
Filipino you know all of his siblings
are full full of you know because my
grandparents are from the Philippines
but my grandma when they when she took
them over to the Philippines she was
like don't talk because they'll know
you're American and then like they'll
try to like take advantage of you don't
try to steal yeah yeah they'll try to
take money from you and stuff because
the police is kind of corrupt over there
I heard too and so the yeah she's like
let me do all the talking my grandma
said the same thing but it wasn't for
scams it was just because she was afraid
people would think I'm dumb judge you
yeah
there's been a brand on it that's true
power dumbness Julie what Caillou China
young tree behind reversing as well 100%
Chinese yeah yeah I guess Cantonese
specifically it's a strange because it's
changed over the years before a lot of
people thought I was like a Japanese mix
no no because you're into anime stuff
maybe no or or either that I don't know
they said it was like basically my eye
in my face shape yeah your face shape
this time Japanese I don't know about
that but then because of the Korean Wave
like people thought that I was these
stations all look the same you know look
at that's racist joke it is pretty
racist but I mean like I don't know in
my school it was a lot of second gen
kids so that's all I mean it was legit
like 90 90 95 % you'll see like the
token white kids token black kids some
Hispanics but like not a lot or yeah not
a lot of uh yeah now the city so by the
time I moved out to cast eight Long
Beach I had a huge culture shock dude
like even though I've been living I was
born here and I lived here and then what
went off to college I was eighteen
eighteen years of my [ __ ] life I only
knew about Asians yeah so but by the
time I went to college I was like oh my
god there's so many other ethnicities I
was like what the [ __ ] I got so many
black I think that's what people don't
know about
la is don't see they'll see
entertainment and everything's like this
multicultural bunch of friends my good
la is hell is segregating like you were
born and raised in LA
it's very segregated that's why this
group of friends is interesting because
like that doesn't really happen in LA
for real though like once I went out to
college I was I realized how ignorant I
have [ __ ] was because I like to have
I've never seen so many like literally
the first thought I had was I've never
seen so many white people in one area
yeah there's like no white people in
this area for the most part like in
there that we're out which is like east
of LA like this little like microcosm of
the San Gabriel Valley is just mostly
Asian and I can't get away from why
exactly but then like if you
damn grow up in Ladera heights in yes
that that was black within my dad we he
was working at Beverly Hills at one
point and so he's like you should go
here and get education so I was like
there and then like like from in
development rial the way from middle
high I was in like the diverse nicely
white people and I was just like yeah I
can't hang on my old high school friends
cuz they had a birthday and I was like
oh I forgot I was usually like cuz that
one I hang out I it's much more diverse
like my adult prints but like like oh
man forgot I'm like the token black guy
in this way notice it until you love to
yeah for all of my schools that I've
been been to like there's probably been
like less than ten white kids in my
class tree school photo like the class
photos right like kindergarten first
grade all that like you see a whole
shift in the community because like
kindergarten no just be like white and
Asian kids and few Hispanic couple black
kids and as the like years went on it
just was like all black Oh see that's
how you got into gangs according to
movies if you were it's only you have
more white friends that could have saved
you got me into the craziest drugs oh
yeah that the hard question I was it so
there was zero black people in any of my
classes until high school yeah and they
just happens behind so because that's
like it's the bigger you know district
yeah yeah and even then like it was like
mix Japanese black people like there
were like maybe two other black people
that were full black yeah yeah my high
school we had and we had so few black
people we could literally just count
them on our fingers like it was just
like yeah capital yeah couple there was
like there was like three people three
or four people in my class or whatever
and then past that I guess it's gotten a
little bit more diverse recently but I
remember just being like yeah I like you
it was weird cuz you didn't think about
it until like it was presented to you
and that like kind of see of people or
just like oh that is kind of weird but I
will say there were zero Filipino people
oh really
my first Filipino person like like that
wasn't related to me after high school I
was like were you
filipino and they were like yeah and I
was like meet you in college like if the
wall was waitressing at Chili's I was
like don't think that does like it like
psychologically like I feel like there
is a normative feel of when you see kind
of your kind order tribe yeah you feel
more relaxed because when I yeah when I
was growing up it was majority black and
Mexican and then when I moved out here I
didn't know there were that many Asians
in America period because I didn't like
well Monterey Park is the highest
density of asian-americans in the whole
entire country so it was like a huge
culture shock for me and I was like what
the heck is going on and it feels weird
to see Asian cops Asian politicians keep
everything yeah like you don't feel like
a second-class citizen group you feel
like oh [ __ ] like this place is ran by
my family yeah this is where we hired
yeah yeah I live in Japan in Japan I was
at my hostel lobby like typing something
and then outside there's a black lady
who was like rushing somewhere and she
stopped at the stoplight looked at what
yeah I looked at her and I was like cuz
that was like I think that person that's
all like being out there for like three
days per second which is like she's like
running home typing to her friend some
[ __ ] weirdo
that's like when I'm like we're at a
park or some [ __ ] and and one kid sees
another kid and they're like we're both
kids two dogs walking across the street
that's so true
[Music]